معركه بخموت هي الاعنف والاطول منذ بدء
الهجوم الروسي ضد اوكرانيا هجمات روسيه
متتاليه برا وقصف مدفعي وجوي حذر معه
الناتو من ان روسيا تمهد لهجوم كبير قبل
ايام من مرور عام على بدء الحرب
وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه قالت ان مجموعه
فاجنر الروسيه حققت انتصارات محدوده في
الضواحي الشماليه لباخمت وحسب مركز
الدراسات الحرب الامريكي تعمل القوات
الروسيه على الاستيلاء على قريه افنفيسكي
بعد كرسنالورا حيث يدور قتال عنيف على
الطريق السريع واصبحت بلده الشاسيفيار
الحصن الاخير امام القوات الروسيه لدخول
بينما حفرت اوكرانيا انفاقا حولها لمنع
تقدم الروس وقالت وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه
ان القوات الروسيه تبدل تكتيكاتها
باستمرار فاحيانا تشن هجوما بمجموعات
صغيره وتاره تستخدم عشرات الاشخاص
المستنفرين في هجوم اخر بينما تكثف القصف
الليلي بالصواريخ
نيويورك تايمز نقلت عن مسؤولين اوكرانيين
مطالبه دول الناتو بذخائر للدبابات
وقذائف مدفعيه للقاذفات الغربيه لمواجهه
الهجوم الروسي الواسع كما طالبوا بطائرات
مقاتله
الوضع الراهن في اوكرانيا بمثابه اختبار
لامتلاك زمام المبادره ليس فقط
وانما لحلف الناتو ايضا الذي يخوض سباقا
لوجستيا مع روسيا قبل معركه اوسع